i mean yeah this is like the reason i
want to do this video is because
obviously from talking about these last
few minutes there's a lot of different
possibilities of where you can go
with this character and come on joe
manganiello he's got a relationship with
hbo
true blood remember how sexy he was in
that wolf king man hell yeah
god and he's also a super nerd
that's the thing that i think a lot of
people forget about joe mangano when we
went to comic-con we never said hi to
him but we did go to his party
where we found out like oh this male
model this godlike figure that walks
amongst us regular
folk he's in his back room doing an
underground dungeons and dragons
games simultaneously playing warcraft
reading a comic book so i think he would
really honor the characters that's all
i'm saying is that
i think he could be one of those actors
who's involved with the writers who can
actually make this a damn good show who
can make it a passion project yeah
how's it going reject nation gregan and
john
john is his name i'm gonna do like i'm
gonna do lex luthor
hey donald hey goofy versus the son of
crypto
not too far off i suppose so saw this
going around on twitter today fans want
to see hbo max revive the deathstroke
storyline with joe manganiello
i still do not pronounce that manganella
that's usually how i feel
i'm sure there's a pronunciation in
italian that's like way more complicated
it sounds
complicated man manganello
i want to play that stroke for hbo max
yeah deathstroke hbo max you know i was
trying to research who started this
and i i can't tell if it's actually joe
manganiello
who spearheaded this secret he's been a
champion for
restored the snyder verse as a lot of us
have been
and i was saying you know a couple
videos a couple weeks ago
how if there's one way we can at least
at minimum continue the snyder verse
is perhaps through spin-off series
through hbo max i was talking like a
cyborg one
i didn't say deathstroke and i'm ashamed
of myself for not
having said deathstroke because
deathstroke would be a perfect one
to do for hbo max it's no this is not
hyperbole this is
very real where i'm coming from here
deathstroke is a character who i've
always been very drawn to
weirdly it was a tv show that got me
super hooked into deathstroke and got me
more fascinated with his actual origin
and whatnot and it was actually the show
arrow and if any of you guys have seen
the series arrow
season two is arguably the best season
out of them all where deathstroke was
the main villain
in that season and he continued on as a
reoccurring character throughout the
series
but that's not even an accurate origin
portrayal of the character
and then when you see joe manganiello in
the role of deathstroke in the snyder
films
i mean how do you feel because whenever
i see joe manganiello uh
appear at all he just seems to have
lived in this
he's only got like five minutes of
screen time or something it's not much
but whenever he's there
there's an impact there's a presence
about him and it feels so
lived in that this little just even an
image of him you're like
yeah joe manganiello embodies this role
yeah i want it's i don't know i mean
zack snyder has like a five-hour cut of
justice league and part of me wonders if
there's not more with that character
because i totally agree it suggests
every time he shows up just in the
portrayal of the character that
he clearly put work into it clearly he's
invested in it
and what we've seen on the big screen or
whatever screens so far of him he goes
through a lot of like
image shifts too like his visage changes
over time so it seems like he's also had
this weird little
truncated on-screen history anyway that
it would be nice to see
some actual flesh behind one thing that
he was saying was when they were working
on the batman
that one thing they really wanted to
bring to life was the arkham origins
fight scene that became incredibly
popular just that
isolated cinematic scene alone and they
wanted to kind of capture that with the
fight scenes and hbo max they have the
series warrior which
has incredible fight scenes and so i'm
like well
you guys have proven that you can
produce a television show with
incredible fight scenes
you can do that as well if you have a
slade wilson series and that's kind of
where i'm coming from here in terms of a
series that i would love to see it would
be slade wilson focused because in zack
snyder's justice league what we're
getting is deathstroke
not really slade wilson where slade
wilson himself
has quite a you know of course every
comic book character they have histories
that have been reinvented i don't know
exactly what the discussions were with
zack snyder of which direction did we
want to take slave wilson and which
origins did we want to borrow from
because clearly
you know zack snyder is not shy of
taking some liberty with characters from
time to time but you know some basic
ones are
he has a war background genetically
experimented on to become like a super
soldier
i think if i'm not mistaken his first
encounter
when he was like a super villain was
actually with the teen titans
which got me thinking which this is
where my mind was going was how doom
patrol was a dc universe app series then
went to hbo
and it just seems like eventually shows
like titans will
go over to hbo just exclusively
i'm wondering like well if those are
tied in and the goal is to have this
multiverse connection where everything
is
ultimately tied into each other i feel
like tonally deathstroke
could blend or mesh well with kind of
the version that they have with titans
if they can do
kind of a slice of the snyder verse
world
use joe manganiello use that specific
deathstroke and it would be neat to see
him kind of cross over into doom patrol
and cross over into titans that way we
are doing that thing we were connecting
all the worlds right there yeah yeah
yeah what i mean for a deathstroke
show theoretically just the level that
character exists upon
i feel like created an interesting lane
for a dc property that is a bit more
martial arts or hand-to-hand combat
based at least and also
be something that you could have your
super stuff on the periphery but you
wouldn't have to rely on it so think
about the
boost that you know you could get in
terms of set pieces for that i don't
know it seems like a show that would
have
a lot of possibility and it would give a
lot of people like me who aren't as
familiar with the deeper cut history of
that character in
actual intro you know because that's a
character who's like very distinct
when you see him in justice league but
obviously at least as of this
live-action portrayal there's a ton
that you could unpack and reveal to us
and yeah the more they bring these shows
into hbo max because it seems like
that's the main hub where everything can
exist
the further they get into putting more
programming in the dc
universe on there yeah i mean it seems
like it would make sense and also
too i mean even if they don't want to
continue the
snyder verse specifically they're still
keeping characters around so i feel like
even if the snyder verse doesn't get
restored this could still be a
possibility if enough people hop on this
particular hashtag
yes well i feel like it would be pretty
cool to kind of explain the events of
what happened with batman
because it's easy to look at a
deathstroke character and go one-eyed
mercenary
super soldier we think of fight scenes
with batman and even just the little
glimpses that we got
with slade wilson in zack snyder's
justice league slade wilson is actually
a big romantic
he's he's a heavy romantic and he's had
a family one of his sons
um grant yes grant
eventually becomes ravager in the comics
and i think if i'm not mistaken the
arrowverse did explore that at one point
i think i don't know my memory's a
little foggy on the show but that's my
point is that he is a family man
and there's that line uh in zack
snyder's justice league where lex does
say let me guess an eye for an eye of
why you're going out unless you want to
do your
lex luthor impression eye for eye
will they have the best you're gonna get
there's something very personal for why
slade wilson is going after batman i
think it would be really cool if maybe
just maybe we were able to get an
episode dedicated to that
where he encounters batman but you never
see bruce wayne
yeah you only see batman and even if it
is ben affleck reprising the role you
would still only see him as batman
so it would be strictly through slade
wilson's perspective
so that way you're in his shoes like
kind of the flipparoo where in zack
snyder's justice league it's like okay
villain who wants to go after batman
that's what's being teased
but if you do the show and you explore
that event and you see it through slade
wilson's perspective where he views
batman as the villain
i think that would just be a great way
to really acknowledge that and show it's
snyder burst connections as well yeah
absolutely
you have you should be a writer no
it's too much time and the last thing i
want to make sure i get the samurai
because remember the group is called
hive
what does hive stand for yes hierarchy
of international vengeance and
extermination it was a group that
slayed wilson after leaving the army
when he was just in his mercenary days
there's this whole history
involving these this group of characters
that i think would be cool to explore
within the season's worth of television
as well considering how
significant they are to how they
impacted his story moving
forward as well so i just think there's
a lot to pull from more than just you
need him to encounter batman you would
have the heart of him being a family man
and then you get the cool missions and
all the different
worlds and avenues to explore and then
yeah you can encounter batman down the
road
this is awesome stuff man and joe mcnell
is great the reason i want to do this
video is because obviously from talking
about these last few minutes there's a
lot of different possibilities of where
you can go
with this character and come on joe
manganiello he's got a relationship with
hbo true blood remember how sexy he was
in that
wolf king man hell yeah god and he's
also a super
nerd that's the thing that i think a lot
of people forget about joe mangano when
we went to comic-con we never said hi to
him but we did go to his party
where we found out like oh this male
model this godlike
figure that walks amongst us regular
folk he's in his back room doing an
underground dungeons and dragons games
while simultaneously playing warcraft
reading a comic book
so i think he would really honor the
characters that's all i'm saying is that
i think he could be one of those actors
who's involved with the writers who can
actually make this a damn good show who
can make it a passion project yeah but
anyway guys hashtag deathstroke for hbo
max do you want this to happen
john do you want it to happen i wanted
it to happen before anyone
else i started the hashtag you guys are
all a bunch of posers
you're not a true deathstroke fan like
me
[ __ ] it is perfect casting yeah
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
lance door listen guys if there's anyone
that could be deathstroke
at our patreon page it's lance just
think about it
right now guys engaged has a family
firefighter
working for the enforcements and
bam fire takes out one of his eyes
hospitalized what are they gonna do they
inject lance with a serum
can we make him stronger than before oh
he starts having emotional mood swings
and [ __ ]
boom they kill his wife and child
so he seeks revenge bam after killing
hundreds of people in canada
where it's extremely crazy whoa john
please i mean i'm not
trying to get that crazy smacking
smacking people are the canadians after
all though right they're not gonna
sorry damn finds out wife and kid are
actually
alive and then he goes toe-to-toe with
his brother saber tooth
bam they fight each other what's that
the merc with the mouth doesn't have a
mouth anymore oh no
oh no what are they going to never hear
and then half the universe snapped away
what is lance thinking door stroke
coming to hbo max
this summer find out what he said thanks
for being our patreon page